They told me that I was born I was born like a
random person and I was going to die like a
random person I was going to be the object of
many people and I had to serve
those men and women who
used my body they saw me carry and they were going to
see me as a  merchandise like those
cokes that we bought at the store like
those chips that we eat so delicious
I was him he I
was that new product that
people needed at that time
[Music]
missing Twenty present in the Us before
I'm from Mexico City my  The
good past has been since I was five years old. I
come from a very dysfunctional family
where there were beatings. Where there was an
absent mother, I find a person who
convinced me to leave my house. He
was 22 and I was 12. The only thing I
wanted and what I want
everyone understands It's that I wanted a
family a family that I didn't have
a family I lived in a 4x4 room
with my family of six people and this
person shows me a house a car like
an elegant life full of money
full of luxuries  The first months were
the happiest of my life I didn't wash, I didn't
iron, it was like the
porcelain doll, it was the princess, that
Fairy Tale that I had been waiting for so long, it turns out that after
three months he decides to prostitute
me, he starts telling me when I had to
get paid With  how many men did I have to
sleep with the time I had to be
there the positions the nude everything I
had to do with a person who
was going to pay me for something I didn't want
and at that moment I
thought it was like a joke they take me to
a brothel there begins my whole
story at the age of 12 where I was
constantly abused the first day the first
day they hit me they spit in my face they
train you to smile so as not to feel so
as not to cry you have to put up with they
hit me with sticks with  chains with
wires got to burn me with an
iron I started to put on little skirts
I started to walk with very very
high heels, one of those glass ones that we normally
see in table dances I started
trying to walk very straight they
began to teach me all of that was
like  an etiquette practice but in
another aspect sometimes people do not believe it
and people do not understand it but
we even had to deal
more than 30 times in a single day with
people who come from the bottom
up and have a very strong position
we had to attend to them we couldn't
ask questions we couldn't recognize
anyone I remember a lot that every time
they hit me they gave me roses I hate roses
my life I don't like roses at all
but it was always forgiveness after a
blow after massacring me on the floor
after getting bruises on my
body after seeing me cry and suffer they
gave you a rose saying they
loved you I
had a pregnancy from my first
month of pregnancy to eight months of
pregnancy I was working with a
huge belly here at 14 years old I
My daughter motivated this when my daughter was born
at 8 and a half months almost 8 half months
this was taken from me three months after she was
born I
had her by caesarean section and they sent me to
work like this and I remember a lot that I didn't
see her for a year  I didn't know if I was sleeping I didn't
know if I was wearing shoes I didn't know if I had already
raped, killed or sold him Even as a
child that I was before having my daughter I
always put a stuffed animal in my belly
saying that I was going to be the best mom in the
world and  that I was going to have Well, what I
always wanted what I always wanted to be able to
give her love, give her affection, give her everything and
unfortunately I couldn't when they
handed her over to me, they handed her over to me with a
burn on my cheek that somehow I
said never, ever, they
're going to hurt someone  my daughter
[Music]
I understood that only love
really comes from the heart for a person
who defended me Cloak and dagger or not a
client who paid me for sex always
paid me to talk to understand me to listen to me
and I listen to him he knows
He fell in love with me and that person, after
thousands of people who abused my
body, was the only person who understood
that I was a human being and that I had to
get out of there. He helped me to escape.
a shelter where they put me the
next day after denouncing and after that I
began to understand what love is again
National
and it taught me to be able to grow with myself
to be able to be a mother to be able to understand what
true love was I didn't want to do
this  statistics I wanted to live with my
daughter live a normal life get out of all
this because I was quite scared and I
did it